I would actually rather be rejected for
being authentic been loved for something
that I'm not
demi lovato is opening up about
everything from how to deal with body
image issues new music and why she
stopped acting on Ashley Graham's pretty
big deal podcast I'm in a new chapter in
my life
during the sit-down the 27 year old got
candid about running herself into the
ground with three a day workouts and
diets which led to her 2018 overdose
I thought the past few years was
recovery from an eating disorder when it
actually was just completely falling
into it I was just running myself into
the ground and I honestly think that's
kind of what led to everything happening
over the past year was just like me
thinking I found recovery when I didn't
and then living this kind of lie and
trying to tell the world I was happy
with myself when I really wasn't
Demi also made it a point to discuss the
pressures women face to look perfect men
have taught us that we are supposed to
focus on our looks before our potential
so of course our power is taken away
when we're distracted by what we look
like the confident singer shed light on
the power of knowing the difference
between body positivity and body
acceptance now when I look in the mirror
and I start to have a negative thought I
don't stop and say no you're beautiful
you're gorgeous I love you you're
perfect the way you are because I don't
believe that so what I say to myself is
nope you're healthy and I accept you oh
and that's all I need to do is accept
you
Dimmie is now easing her way back into
acting after being off the scene for
years mainly because she was insecure
about her weight it goes back to the
whole body acceptance thing okay tell me
I didn't act for so many years because I
was so insecure about my weight I did a
roll on from dusk till dawn which was I
think the last acting gig that I did how
many years ago was that that was
probably 2015 Wow yeah it's been at
least for four years and I haven't done
a sitcom in 10 years
so being back on Will & Grace was like I
actually had to work through some
triggers because it was a sitcom and it
was very fast-paced and it's a comedy so
you're you have to be ready to make
people laugh and put your emotions aside
of whatever you're dealing with but once
I got into it I was like okay as long as
I'm acknowledging the feelings that come
with us and I like announce my triggers
to the people around me I can get
through it so sorry not sorry singer
admits that she's a work in progress
but it's safe to say that she's come a
long way she's learning to honor her
limitations by balancing her mental
health with her career I recently lost a
good friend of mine a couple weeks ago
and I cancelled the studio you know
multiple times that week the old me
would have forced myself to go to the
studio or would have listened to someone
else saying no just get in there see
what you make you know or through power
through it exactly exactly that's what
I'm talking about and I really allowed
myself I took days off from my
scheduling and that way I was able to
really process it and grieve Dimmie also
opened up about the importance of
boundaries specifically with family you
can't set boundaries with people unless
you respect yourself enough to know why
you're having to set these boundaries
with people and most of the boundaries
I've learned yes they start with friends
but a lot of times it starts with
families one of my favorite sayings is
no one pushes your buttons like your
family does because they're the ones
that put them there well when it comes
to new music Dimmie revealed that she's
in the process of creating a new anthem
I was in the studio and I was working
with one of my favorite producers oak we
were writing and we were like making
this song it was like an anthem about
like body positivity because I was like
we need we need an anthem when I go into
the next chapter of my career what do I
want it to be because I've always done
the sexy route I've never really done
the whole like feeling comfortable in
yourself like I don't have to be in a
one-piece leotard on stage Jimmy has
pretty much always been an open book
when it comes to body image
et sat down with the singer in 2017
where she shared some advice on how to
deal with body shamers I focus on just
what I see in the mirror and that's a
beautiful person and regardless of what
I think of my body that day I know that
nobody can take Who I am away from
[Music]